En s'agissant d'une période de rentrée, je trouve que c'est toujours important de renouveler les convictions et des résolutions qui puissent s'accorder à ce qui pourrait être véritablement le plus désirable pour nous,
le plus digne et le plus noble en tant que projet de vie.
C'est toujours très important d'être clair et objectif par rapport à des projets légitimes que nous avons pour la vie, mais malheureusement à cause des distractions de ces mondes,
nous sommes parfois amenés à troubler nos vues par rapport à ce qui doit être la définition véritable de nous en tant que chrétiens.
Donc ces textes que nous venons de lire, c'est un texte qui nous montre deux des sujets les plus importants que nous pouvons trouver à propos de nous-mêmes et dans la parole de Dieu.
Ce texte nous démontre la conversion authentique d'un homme qui pourrait sembler aux yeux naturels une personne très difficile à se convertir,
un homme très influent d'une nation lointaine, écartée de la connaissance du Dieu véritable.
Et nous voyons la conversion authentique de cet homme.
Mais ces textes montrent que la conversion authentique de cet homme était liée, ou était les résultats ou les fruits, d'une évangélisation véritablement biblique.
Et malheureusement, dans nos jours, on voit beaucoup de confusion au sein de l'Église par rapport à ces deux choses.
Comment nous devrions pratiquer l'évangélisation ?
Car la nature de l'évangélisation est déterminante pour considérer la nature du résultat de l'évangélisation qui est la conversion.
Donc d'un côté, une mauvaise compréhension de ce qui est l'évangélisation,
et de l'autre côté, une mauvaise compréhension de ce qui est la conversion véritable, authentique.
Et même si les Églises peuvent grandir numériquement, nominalement,
car elles utilisent des moyens faux, erronés d'évangélisation,
les résultats sont des fausses conversions.
Et ici, nous voyons la richesse de ce texte qui nous parle de ces deux vérités cruciales.
qui a à voir avec la manière dont on fait face au défi de la vie,
car si nous n'avons pas une réponse satisfatoire biblique pour cette question,
est-ce que je suis sauvé ou non ?
Je n'arriverai pas à vivre en paix,
et encore moins mourir en paix.
Quel sera le destin éternel de nos âmes ?
Et donc ces textes enseignent l'Église,
ce qui est l'évangélisation.
Et nous devrions
accrocher nos égards
à la parole de Dieu,
car nous n'avons qu'est les Nouveaux Testaments
comme paramètres inhérents pour nous,
pour savoir ce qui est la vraie évangélisation
et ce qui est la vraie conversion.
Si nous ne sommes qu'accrochés
à ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui,
et lorsqu'on considère toute la variété des manières
dont les personnes partagent l'Évangile,
et considère que les personnes sont converties,
avec quelle vitesse elles baptisent les personnes,
avec ou sans évidence convaincante des conversions,
qu'est-ce qui fait partie du contenu,
du partage de l'Évangile,
si c'est qui est un Jésus-Thème
où il va changer ta vie,
il va améliorer ta vie,
ou si c'est vraiment Christ à la croix.
Nous ne pouvons pas nous dire tout simplement
que Dieu peut utiliser
toute cette variété
d'évangélisation.
Car nous avons,
Dieu nous a laissé de manière très claire,
un paramètre.
Et le paramètre est celui de la Bible.
Donc ici nous sommes devant
l'évangélisation efficace selon la Bible.
Et ce texte, il est rempli
des contrastes qui sont très riches.
Donc juste avant ces passages
qu'on vient de lire,
encore dans le chapitre 8,
nous voyons la fausse conversion
d'un autre homme très influent
dans sa ville, dans sa région.
Les magiciens Simon,
samaritains,
qu'au milieu d'une espèce de réveil,
Philippe arrive,
Dieu utilise Philippe pour prêcher l'évangile
et confirme la prédication
de Philippe
par beaucoup de chassements de démons
et des miracles.
C'est Simon, magicien,
qui semble avoir cru à ce que Philippe disait,
est plus intéressé à la puissance,
à la prospérité terrestre,
au changement des circonstances,
à l'amélioration des vies.
Et heureusement
que les apôtres
arrivent pour voir ce qui se passe
en Samarie
et en ayant communiqué
les Saint-Esprits
à ceux qui étaient convertis
et baptisés,
Simon, le magicien,
révèle de manière explicite
quel était son vrai intérêt
envers la foi chrétienne.
Ce n'était pas Christ
ou la conversion,
c'était
avoir la capacité
d'utiliser une puissance
et même
de domestiquer
les Saint-Esprits
et il offre
de l'argent
aux apôtres
pour qu'ils puissent
recevoir la capacité
de communiquer
les Saint-Esprits.
Et donc,
par là,
les apôtres constatent
qu'il n'était pas vraiment converti
et même s'il avait été baptisé
sur la base
de sa déclaration
des fois,
répéter
une phrase publiquement
ou une prière publiquement
ne suffit pas
pour se convertir.
Et donc,
il est coupé
de la commune de l'Église.
Il est reconnu publiquement
comme un non-chrétien.
Sa vie n'était pas
en harmonie
avec sa profession des fois.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
nous voyons
les succès
de l'évangélisation
de Philippe
avec ses bémols
d'une fausse conversion
et un nettoyage
providential
des dieux.
Car imaginons
comment ces magiciens
qui sont présents
dans les Églises
évangéliques
de nos jours
causent et provoquent
des dégâts
quand ils veulent jouer
avec ces puissances
des prospérités terrestres.
L'Évangile
de la prospérité
est triomphaliste.
Et l'Église
de Saint-Marie
a nettoyé
de cette possible
mauvaise influence
car c'était déjà
une personne très influente
qui s'est dit
à convertir
quand elle n'était
pas vraiment convertie.
Donc,
quand on arrive
au verset 26,
un ange du Seigneur
va appaître Philippe
et dire
lève-toi
vers le midi
sur le chemin
qui descend
Jérusalem à Gaza
ces lieux
déserts.
Donc,
attention,
quel contraste.
Dieu va quitter
Philippe
de cette évangélisation
spectaculaire
couverte
de miracles
de multitude
de personnes
pour faire
une évangélisation
qui aboutira
avec beaucoup
d'efficacité
dans les saluts
d'un autre homme
aussi très important
dans la société.
Sauf que
cette évangélisation
efficace
se passe
de manière
très souple,
sans aucun signe
spectaculaire,
sans chassement
de démons,
sans miracle,
tout simplement
ancré
dans la proclamation
de l'Évangile
selon l'Écriture.
Toutes les conversions
véritables sont variables,
y compris
de ceux qui sont
vraiment convertis
en samaritaine
et de celles
des lénus
que tuopiens.
Sauf que
Philippe reste
pour nous
un modèle
d'évangélisation.
Et donc,
mon but aujourd'hui,
c'est de renouveler
notre conviction
en tant que chrétien
par rapport
à quelle est
notre identité
principale,
quelle est
la signification
principale
de nos vies
de ces côtés-ci
de la gloire.
Car la signification
sublime
de notre vie,
c'est adorer
Dieu.
Nous pouvons
le faire
dès aujourd'hui,
nous le ferons
davantage
pour toute l'éternité.
Par contre,
il nous reste
encore une autre
chose à faire
qui est
insurmontable
par rapport
à n'importe
quel autre type
d'objectif
de vie.
Et c'est
de conduire
d'autres personnes
au salut,
à la réconciliation
avec Dieu
et à l'adoration.
L'évangélisation
existe car
l'adoration
n'existe pas
encore pour beaucoup.
Et il n'y a
aucune chose
plus pertinente,
significative
qu'on puisse faire
dans cette vie
qui est de partager
l'évangile
pour que nos semblables
se réconcilient
avec Dieu
et vivent
pour toute l'éternité
en réjouissant
de la vraie joie
de la vie,
la communion
avec Dieu.
Ce qui est intéressant
à remarquer
dès le départ,
c'est la manière
très intentionnelle
dont le Saint-Esprit
a inspiré
la parole
de Dieu
pour nous informer
de notre participation
dans ce projet
de Dieu
qui est
son agence
numéro un
dans ce monde.
Il a prolongé
sa patience
envers une race
de rebelles
pour offrir
à cette même race
l'opportunité
de réconciliation.
Le travail
numéro un
des dieux
donc
envers nous
dans cette condition
c'est
de racheter
un peuple
pour soi.
Et la Bible
donc nous révèle
par là
un rappel
de la gloire
de Dieu
qui peut
satisfaire
l'âme humaine
et la manière
dont nous pouvons
le réconcilier
avec Dieu.
Sauf que Dieu
va inclure aussi
notre participation
dans sa manière
de sauver
l'humanité.
Et pourquoi
je suis en train
de présenter
de cette manière ?
Car quand on s'approche
de la Bible
on a une tendance
très égoïste,
médiocre
de chercher
des réponses
à nos petits problèmes
du quotidien
qui touchent
à des attentes
très souvent erronées
par rapport aux choses
qui peuvent vraiment
nous satisfaire.
Si au moins
ça changerait
dans ma vie,
si au moins
ces circonstances
s'amélioreraient.
Sauf que la Bible
ici
elle a une structure
très intentionnelle
et lorsque
au verset 26
nous voyons
que l'ange
va rediriger
Philippe
de là où il était
Samarie
envers les déserts
à Gaza
pour rencontrer
un Éthiopien
nous voyons
que nous ne pouvons
pas jouer
une roulette rousse
avec la Bible.
Retourner la Bible
au hasard
et attendre
qu'un verset
nous touche.
Dieu
des fois
dans sa grâce
et sa miséricorde
il peut le baigner.
mais ça peut tomber
aussi dans des versets
très effrayants
et nous pouvons
devenir névrotiques
envers la vie.
Par contre
lorsqu'il
Luc va décrire
avec sa
mentalité
des recherchers
des médecins
comme il était
il va faire
exprès
de manière
très intentionnelle
sous l'inspiration
de Saint-Esprit
de nous dire
au départ
au chapitre 1
qu'il est Christ
avant
son ascension
à Dieu disciple
qu'il allait
recevoir
les Saint-Esprit
des dieux
il y a une question
intéressante
juste après
où les disciples
disent
mais c'est
cette puissance
de Saint-Esprit
c'est pour la
prospérité terrestre
c'est là
où tu vas
restaurer
les royaumes
sur terre
et Jésus
va couper
cette compréhension
par rapport
au Saint-Esprit
pour démontrer
l'une des fonctions
principales
du Saint-Esprit
non
vous recevrez
le Saint-Esprit
et vous
serrez
attention
il ne dit pas
vous allez faire
de l'évangélisation
il dit
vous serrez
mes témoins
quelle est
la fonction
principale
du Saint-Esprit
révéler
Christ
à nous
car
personne
ne peut être
un témoin
de Jésus
Christ
en ayant
entendu
d'un autre
qui est Jésus
Christ
on entend
d'un autre
qui est Jésus
Christ
mais il faut
que cette
entente
écoute
devienne
une connaissance
réelle
expérimentale
salvatrice
de Jésus
Christ
quelqu'un
m'a partagé
l'évangile
plusieurs fois
et plusieurs fois
je ne suis pas
converti
mais à un moment donné
à travers
cette présentation
de l'évangile
Christ
est devenu
réel
mon sauveur
ma relation
avec lui
est devenue
personnelle
par l'oeuvre
du Saint-Esprit
qui a révélé
son fils
en moi
et à partir
de là
je ne peux pas
m'empêcher
de devenir
un témoin
vivant
du Christ
la conception
des témoins
c'est la conception
monculaires
si vous voulez
c'est la conception
de ceux
qui ont vu
qui ont connu
et pas tout simplement
de ceux
qui ont entendu
parler
et donc
vous allez recevoir
les Saint-Esprits
et vous serez
mes témoins
verset 8
du chapitre 1
dit
à Jérusalem
dans toute la Judée
dans la Samarie
et jusqu'aux extrémités
de la terre
donc quel est
l'intérêt
des Luc
depuis les débuts
du livre d'Actes
c'est de laisser
très clair
à toutes les personnes
intelligentes
pour plus simple
qu'elles soient
que Actes
est l'enregistrement
initial
et paradigmatique
c'est un paradigme
pour toute l'Église
pour toute l'histoire
de l'Église
que les Seigneurs
Jésus-Christ
à travers ses disciples
dans la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
est en train
d'accomplir
cette promesse
je vous enverrai
à l'Église
et à l'Église
vous serrez
mes témoins
et l'Évangile
va pénétrer
toutes les extrémités
de la terre
et pourquoi
nous pouvons l'affirmer
avec toute clarté
c'est qu'à
au chapitre 8
et c'est un peu
la suture
du livre d'Actes
à chaque fois
que l'Église
va pénétrer
dans une de ces régions
qui Christ a définies
Luc va marquer
avec clarté
donc au chapitre 8
juste après
qu'Étienne soit
lapidé
jusqu'à la mort
par les Juifs
sous les consentiments
des Seuls
avant sa conversion
la Bible
va nous démontrer
il y a une phrase
qui est très décourageante
par rapport
au trafic des drogues
à Rio
qu'on a entendu une fois
dans le délégué
on faisait un travail
dans une pénitentiaire
avec l'Église
et il nous expliquait
un peu la difficulté
il dit
ceux qui sont mêlés
au trafic des drogues
dans les favelas
sont les seuls
qui prospèrent
dans cet environnement
et cela devient
une tentation énorme
et la plupart
de ceux qui
vont se mêler
avec les trafics
et qui sont exécutés
sont des jeunes
pas du tout entraînés
entre 12
et 25 ans
et il a dit
et le pire
c'est qu'à l'instant même
où
un d'entre eux
est mort
il y a déjà
un queue énorme
d'autres qui veulent
rentrer
du trafic
il a dit
c'est comme si
c'était une bataille
insurmontable
à cause
de cette inégalité
bon ça c'est très tragique
mais
c'est un exemple
véritable aussi
du bon côté
de la force
il y a un Étienne
qui est mort
en proclamant
l'évangile
et un Philippe
qui va apparaître
tout de suite
pour faire
les royaumes
des dieux avancés
c'est comme
Tertolien a dit
les sangs des martyrs
sont la sémence
de l'église
c'est inexplicable
à part
l'aspect surnaturel
de la puissance
de l'évangélisation
dans la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
qui est dans une zone
complètement inconfortable
risque d'être mort
tous les temps
l'église
prospère
énormément
depuis ses premières années
et donc ici
nous voyons
un Philippe
qui va apparaître
et le texte
qui nous dit
qu'à partir de là
une persécution
s'éléva
contre l'église
de Jérusalem
et tous
furent dispersés
dans les contrées
de quelle région
quelle était
la promesse
du Christ
vous serez
mes témoins
en Jérusalem
et en
Judée
Samarie
et donc
des fois
nous ne pouvons pas
attendre
notre propre
volonté
pour aller
faire les missions
ça semble
pas confortable
pas
accordé
à nos attentes
à ce qu'on avait
projeté
pour la vie
ça peut
sembler
pas encore
les moments
j'ai pas encore
vu une révélation
comme celle
des linges
qui va bientôt
apparaître
à Philippe
par contre
un bouleversement
social
va couper
tous les vrais
chrétiens
de leur vie
normale
et la persécution
était la manière
de Dieu
d'éparpiller
les chrétiens
afin que l'église
attende
d'autres endroits
des fois
Dieu a besoin
de faire
ces choses
avec nous
bouleverser
nos vies
pour qu'on soit
sécoué
éveillé
afin qu'on
atteigne les buts
les plus nobles
de notre existence
pour qu'on soit
plus joyeux
et donc
l'église
regardez bien
dans les contrées
de la Judée
et de la Samarie
à l'exception
des apôtres
et ça c'est aussi
très intéressant
car l'église
base
mère
elle était là
et tous ces ministères
étaient plus en moins
connectés à Jérusalem
afin qu'à partir
de là
l'église puisse avoir
une légitimité
de continuité
et c'est intéressant
car les apôtres
qui étaient les fondements
de l'église
ils ont dû avoir
le courage
de rester à Jérusalem
et presque la totalité
des apôtres
seront morts
à Jérusalem
sous persécution
Lloyd-Jones
un jour
il raconte
la manière dont
une famille
des missionnaires
à cause
d'une
guerre civile
qui avait été déclenchée
dans les pays
où ils étaient
ils décident
de rentrer
à leur pays
sauf que
dans les chemins
ils avaient
cet arrêt
à Londres
et ils profitent
pour aller
à l'église
de Lloyd-Jones
et Lloyd-Jones
ils prêchent
sur les missions
et les evangelisations
et à la fin du culte
ils viennent à Lloyd-Jones
pour dire
on était prêt
à rentrer
à notre pays
sauf que maintenant
on va rentrer
au champ missionnaire
et c'était la même chose
pour Calvin
car plusieurs
d'entre les réformés
qui étaient présents
en France
sous la persécution
catholique
de la contre-réforme
partaient
pour les réfuges
en Genève
et ils étaient
juste un peu plus
entraînés
et renvoyaient
en France
pour mourir
et verser leur sang
pour l'évangile
et donc
les apôtres restent
l'église laïque
et c'est ça
qui est un point
très important pour nous
est dispersée
après
les apôtres
reviendront
pour établir
des pasteurs
dans toutes les églises
mais dans un premier moment
cette évangile
de la région
des Judées
et des Saint-Marie
l'accomplissement
de la promesse
du Christ
ne dépend pas
des professionnels
de l'évangélisation
nous sommes tous
témoins
la promesse
concerne tous
tous les chrétiens
et donc
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
l'intérêt de Luc
en acte
c'est de retracer
comment cette promesse
faite en acte 1
s'accomplit
progressivement
en pénétrant
Judée
Saint-Marie
et qu'est-ce
qui nous manque
jusqu'aux extrémités
de la terre
le chapitre 8
d'acte
on voit
cette évangélisation
de Saint-Marie
par la puissance
des dieux
à travers
les ministères
de Philippe
et
pendant
attention
ce que je vais vous dire
maintenant
pendant que Philippe
est en train
d'obéir
de manière
très ordinaire
l'appel
à faire
l'évangélisation
une révélation
spectaculaire
a lieu
c'est pas
attendre d'abord
la révélation
spectaculaire
pour après
m'élancer
peut-être
qu'on aura
plus d'expériences
spectaculaires
d'évangélisation
si nous sommes
déjà
en cours
des routes
et donc
au verset 26
un ange
du Seigneur
va s'adresser
à Philippe
donc
l'objectif
pour nous
la vérité
centrale
pour nous
c'est que
témoigner
est l'un des
objectifs
suprêmes
de chaque
chrétien
et la question
pour nous
clé
c'est comment
les modèles
d'évangélisation
de Philippe
doivent guider
et enflammer
notre témoignage
chrétien
donc Philippe
il était
quelque part
quelqu'un appelé
un ministère
exceptionnel
dans un moment
de l'église
il était
un évangéliste
avec un E majuscule
si vous voulez
il était aussi
l'un des précurseurs
des diacres
son profil
est décrit
en acte 6
quand il est décrit
comme quelqu'un
rempli
de son esprit
avec un coeur
humble
pour servir
à l'église
de manière
très pratique
en diacre
mais qui avait
quelque chose
de plus
donc il avait
des qualifications
comme la qualification
des anciens
sauf que
l'évangéliste
selon la Bible
c'est notre conception
plus moderne
des missionnaires
car un missionnaire
n'est pas en termes
de vie
et un missionnaire
n'est pas quelqu'un
qui va tout simplement
dire
j'ai envie
de partir
et partager
l'évangile
cette personne
doit être confirmée
doit être évaluée
elle doit avoir
les mêmes qualifications
et possiblement
les mêmes entraînements
qu'un ancien
car l'évangéliste
selon la Bible
ce sont ceux
qui vont faire
l'évangélisation
dans des endroits
où l'église
n'est pas encore
et leur objectif
c'est d'implanter
des églises
ce n'est pas
tout simplement
de partager l'évangélisme
de manière individuelle
aux personnes
et donc Philippe
il est un évangéliste
mais cette promesse
de l'évangélisation
du monde
ne reste pas
qu'avec Philippe
nous tous
devons regarder
les modèles
de Philippe
et accomplir
cet objectif
d'évangélisation
dans nos vies
et donc la question
pour nous
c'est comment son modèle
peut servir
des références
pour nous
afin que nous puissions
embrasser
notre identité
d'évangéliste
des témoins
et la première
marque
qu'on voit ici
chez Philippe
c'est
que nous devons
comme Philippe
être des messagers
soumis
à la direction
du Seigneur
et à la conduite
du Saint-Esprit
donc ici
c'est intéressant
c'est un aspect
un peu plus
subjectif
de la manière
que le Saint-Esprit
peut nous conduire
et nous ne devons
pas avoir peur
car le Saint-Esprit
est un être personnel
qui habite en nous
qui interagit avec nous
et même s'il y a
beaucoup d'aberrations
dans des manières
très erronées
et manipulatrices
donc les personnes
veulent réclamer
interpréter les influences
du Saint-Esprit
aujourd'hui
dans plusieurs cercles chrétiens
cela ne peut pas
supprimer
la réalité
que la Bible nous présente
et que nous vivons
dans nos vies
et donc
du verset 26
au verset 29
on a
la manière
dont son ange
se présente à Philippe
et l'esprit
verset 29
qui va dire
quelque chose
à Philippe
et la première chose
qu'on doit remarquer
par rapport
à cette soumission
au Seigneur Jésus
et à son esprit
c'est la manière
dont le Seigneur Jésus
s'adresse
à Philippe
à travers son ange
donc ici
c'est très important
pour nous
de comprendre
ce que les textes
visent à communiquer
est tellement loin
de ces désirs
que les personnes
ont
dans nos jours
de tout simplement
contempler des anges
des mouvements
d'adoration extravagants
qui attendent
devant un ange
avec un plateau d'or
avec la clé
de la maison
promise
les anges en général
quand ils vont apparaître
dans la Bible
ils sont toujours liés
à des communications
envers
l'avancement
de l'évangile
l'accomplissement
de la venue du Christ
du Sauveur
et ici
c'est la même chose
voici Philippe
en entrant
d'accomplir
la grande mission
en partageant
l'évangile
en Judée
en Samarie
et les seigneurs
Jésus
envoient
un ange
c'est-à-dire
Jésus
il est déjà
élevé
au tronc des dieux
dans les cieux
dans sa position
d'autorité
suprême
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
!
dans les ciels
sur la terre
allez donc
et faites des disciples
et ici
c'est une démonstration
de cette autorité
de Christ
qui est
à l'origine
de l'évangélisation
mondiale
ça nous montre
que peu importe
quels soient
les niveaux
des résistances
culturelles
sociétales
et même
des déclarations
qui disent les personnes
contraires à Jésus
et son évangile
c'est pas avec ces âmes
qu'on va jouer
c'est pas avec
l'expert
de la contextualisation
!
ou des statistiques
c'est avec l'assurance
que les seigneurs
assis sur son trône
et les premiers
intéressés
pour chaque âme
qu'il va sauver
il est déjà mort
pour ces personnes
il a déjà tout expié
il est là en train
de faire son intercession
sur les trônes
des dieux
et il va mobiliser
son église
à croiser
les chemins
d'une personne
par qui
l'Écrit
lui-même
est très intéressé
même s'il est
au désert
très loin
de nous sommes
et un ange
c'est-à-dire
un représentant
un témoin
qui contemple
les Christ
les plus proches
qui est possible
va descendre
comme un messager
afin
que nous aussi
jouons notre rôle
en tant que messager
regarder les privilèges
de faire l'évangélisation
tout comme
l'essai en Jésus
un voie
un ange
à Philippe
Philippe sera envoyé
comme un ange
à l'Eunuque-Éthiopien
il n'y a aucune tâche
qu'il ne peut faire
dans cette vie
qui pourrait être
plus noble
plus digne
que d'être confus
comme un ange
des dieux
qui apporte
les bonnes nouvelles
de salut
et qui représente
dans la vie
de ces personnes
et là c'est très important
pour nous
d'assimiler
cette vérité
ces personnes
qui ont croisé
nos vies
pour nous partager
l'évangile
ces personnes
dont les déviations
sacrificielles
on ne peut même pas connaître
tous ces efforts
ces renoncements
sont des expressions
de l'amour personnel
du Seigneur Jésus
pour vous
et donc
Philippe
il est soumis
à cette autorité
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
qui nous envoie
à l'évangélisation
tous
êtes-vous soumis
à Christ ou non ?
véritablement
ça c'est un signe
d'évaluation
de l'authenticité
de notre profession
des fois
car quand on se convertit
la déclaration
la plus basique
qu'on fait
c'est le Seigneur Jésus
est mon Seigneur
et mon Sauveur
et s'il est mon Seigneur
il me demande
de manifester
cette vérité
par mon obéissance
et donc
Philippe
manifeste
être rempli
du Saint-Esprit
car l'un des ministères
ou l'un des signes
les plus convaincants
de l'agence
du Saint-Esprit
entre nous
n'est pas
les dons spirituels
car quand Paul
a voulu écrire
à propos des dons spirituels
il a dû réprocher
énormément
l'église la plus réprochée
du Nouveau Testament
avec deux lettres
à cause des mauvais usages
des dons
qui devraient être
périphériques
et auxiliaires
au but principal
du Saint-Esprit
faire des dons
des témoins
du Christ
mais quand Paul
veut parler
du remplissage
du Saint-Esprit
les personnes
peuvent pratiquer
les dons du Saint-Esprit
en étant
refroidi
par rapport
aux influences
du Saint-Esprit
en agissant
contrairement même
à l'influence
du Saint-Esprit
et quand il a parlé
d'être rempli
du Saint-Esprit
quel est le terme
le plus récourant
Ephésiens 5 et 6
soumission
ne vous remplissez pas
du vent
dans lequel il y a
de l'ivronnierie
mais soyez remplis
du Saint-Esprit
et qu'est-ce qu'il va dire
à partir de là
soyez soumis
les uns aux autres
femmes au mari
serviteurs
à ses patrons
patron et mari
à Christ
comme Christ l'est
au Seigneur
si vous voulez trouver
un homme rempli
de Saint-Esprit
observez
une femme remplie
de Saint-Esprit
combien ils sont soumis
aux ordonnances
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
y compris
l'ordonnance
de l'évangélisation
c'est une soumission
donc à l'autorité
du Christ
et c'est une soumission
aussi
rapide
prête
un ange du Seigneur
s'adressant à Philippe
lui dit
lève-toi
et va du côté
midi
sur le chemin
qui descend
de Jérusalem
à Gaza
celui qui est désert
il s'élève
et parti
donc quelqu'un
a déjà dit
si Dieu te demande
de s'asseoir
ne cherche même pas
des chaises
il s'élève
et parti
une soumission
à une tâche difficile
Jean-Baptiste
est aussi
parti au désert
pour obéir à Dieu
et Dieu
a provoqué
un réveil
à travers sa vie
un vrai réveil
c'est pas les mercredis
du réveil
qui assurent un réveil
par l'affiche
c'était un message
dur au milieu
du désert
et les personnes venaient
mais ici
c'est intéressant
car
cette soumission
elle était
rapide
mais elle était
une soumission
envers
un endroit
un peu
contre-intuitif
on voit la stratégie
de l'évangélisation
particulièrement
des pôles
d'aller dans
les principales villes
et dans les centres
des principales villes
pour que la diffusion
de l'évangile
soit aussi
intentionnelle
et stratégique
par contre ici
ça nous montre
cette brébie égarée
une par rapport
au 99
Dieu va quitter
Philippe
au milieu
d'une évangélisation
à pleine force
une multitude
de Samarie
qui s'est convertie
avec des miracles
des signes
chassement de démons
et va l'appeler
à sortir
de cet environnement
qui est devenu
possiblement pour lui
et pour beaucoup
très séducteur
maré au site
ministériel
il l'a appelé
pour aller
au milieu
du désert
pour croiser
avec la vie
d'une personne
donc une soumission
qui représente
une déviation
des routes
une soumission
difficile
aller
au désert
quelles sont
les difficultés
envers lesquelles
vous êtes
disposés
à embrasser
de manière
sacrificielle
afin de faire avancer
les roms de Dieu
on a l'habitude
de dire
qu'on a plus d'espace
dans l'agenda
la routine est lourde
mais c'est important
pour nous
d'être très intentionnels
et de considérer
quels sacrifices
nous pouvons faire
pour faire
les roms de Dieu
avancer
nous mettre
à disposition
des dieux
de manière très intentionnelle
afin de partager
l'évangile
séparer un jour
dans les mois
chacun de jours
pour inviter
un voisin
tout simplement
pour passer du temps
et pour partager
l'évangile
mais c'est aussi
une soumission
avantageuse
et c'est là
où je pense
qu'on rate
car on fait tellement
confiance
à nos propres stratégies
envers l'évangile
qu'on oublie
que la soumission
sacrificielle
pour aller
dans les lieux
difficiles
est celle
qui est la plus
récompensée
par Dieu
regardez
qu'est-ce que Dieu
est en train de faire
envers un homme
ou à travers un homme
qui se soumet
c'était une soumission
avantageuse
c'est une soumission
sensible
à la direction
des dieux
du Saint-Esprit
c'est pas un évangélisme
automatique
je suis pas complètement
contre
mais c'est pas tout simplement
un évangélisme
par des tracts
par une espèce
de vomir
des paroles
préconçues
pré dites
c'est un homme
qui est soumis
au Saint-Esprit
rempli du Saint-Esprit
et
Dieu
donc
les conduit
les dirige
de manière
qu'il est mis
dans des positions
très favorables
à l'évangélisation
regardez
ce que le texte dit
verset 27
il s'éleva et partit
et voici
un éthiopien
un eunuque
ministre des Kandas
reine d'Ethiopie
et sur-entendant
de tous les trésors
tous ces trésors
venus à Jérusalem
pour adorer
et s'en retournant
assis
sur son char
et il lisait
les prophètes Esaïe
l'esprit
dit à Philippe
avance
et approche-toi
de ses char
Philippe a couru
et entendit l'éthiopien
qui lisait
les prophètes Esaïe
donc remarquez très bien
il sort
de Samarie
il va vers les déserts
et ici
le texte dit
voilà
l'aspect sacrificiel
encore
à la fin du passage
il sera
élevé
enlevé
et il sera
télétransporté
quelque part
envers une autre région
à Zot
mais le Saint-Esprit
aurait pu le faire déjà
par contre
regardez bien
le timing parfait
de Dieu
pour que même
en courant
et en marchant
et normalement
Dieu va entraîner
beaucoup
de missionnaires
ainsi
en souffrant
beaucoup
ce qui représente
pour lui
une meilleure compréhension
des sacrifices
du Christ
pour lui
et une expression
plus légitime
de son amour
sincère
pour les perdus
imaginez
Léonuc
et Thopien
envoyant
un homme
qui vient
après sa char
en courant
en essayant
de l'annoncer
l'évangile
et pour
!
en fin
en moins
une voiture
cassée
peut nous empêcher
de partager
l'évangile
et là
c'est intéressant
car
il obéit
le Saint-Esprit
lui dit
de courir
même en pouvant
les télétransporter
!
et en course
il essaie de partager
mais regardez l'avantage
c'était l'état
min parfaite de Dieu
pour que cet homme
qui était sincèrement
en train de chercher Dieu
soit en train de lire
l'un des textes
les plus
avantageux
évident
pour Jésus Christ
pour présenter
Jésus Christ
à partir de la Bible
qui dans cette époque-là
était encore
l'Ancien Testament
et donc
c'est avantageux
quand on est soumis
à ces influences
du Saint-Esprit
je me rappelle
au début de ma conversion
j'ai beaucoup prié
j'étais très troublé
en lisant la Bible
par le fait
que malgré
toute l'explicité
et la clarté
du Nouveau Testament
par rapport au fait
que Christ
était le vrai Messie
les Juifs
n'y croyaient pas
bien sûr
les premiers chrétiens
étaient tous des Juifs
mais la majorité
des Juifs
n'ont pas reconnu
les Christ
comme Messie
malgré
toutes les évidences
et j'ai prié Dieu
je dis
Seigneur
donne-moi l'opportunité
de partager l'évangile
en Juif
et dans ma tête
ça serait presque impossible
de trouver un Juif
à Rio
et je suis allé courir
à la plage
et quand je vois
il y a
je ne sais pas
comment vous appelez
un Kang
c'est les draps
qu'on met
à la plage
pour rester sur les draps
c'est ça ?
oui
un type de serviette
qui était tout écrit
avec des lettres hébraïques
moi j'étais déjà au séminaire
donc j'ai su au moins reconnaître
je ne savais pas
ce que cela voulait dire
mais je savais au moins reconnaître
que c'était des lettres hébraïques
et là
un prière m'est venu à la tête
et je me suis dit
waouh
voici la réponse de Dieu
sauf que moi
je n'étais pas très courageux
donc je continue de courir
je ne crois pas
je vais devoir parler
cet homme là
j'ai prié
donc là je dois parler
et je passe par lui
et je me dis
si dans mon retour
il est là encore
je partage
et donc je cours
encore plus loin
quelques kilomètres
pour loin
mais quand je rentre
il est encore là
et donc je m'arrête
je partage
je ne sais pas
quels sont les résultats
mais par la grâce
de Dieu
je t'ai convaincu
que quand on prie
sincèrement
quand on se laisse guider
par le Saint-Esprit
il nous donne des occasions
beaucoup plus fluides
envers l'évangélisation
et c'est intéressant
car quand Mayra
était en train d'étudier
ici
avant notre mariage
à sa faculté
elle était partie
du groupe GBU
et ils ont invité
un ami qui était juif
et les passages spécifiques
qu'ils étaient en train de lire
c'était ces passages là
Isaïe 53
sauf que la seule chose
qu'il avait demandé avant
c'est que
s'il vient
qu'il ne lise pas
les nouveaux testaments
qu'il ne prenne pas un texte
qu'il soit centré
sur Jésus Christ
et le problème
c'est qu'ils ont fait
toute l'étude
et à la fin
il a dit
j'ai une seule chose
à vous reprocher
je vous ai demandé
de ne pas toucher
un texte
du Nouveau Testament
et ils ont tous dit
non mais ce n'est pas du tout
un texte du Nouveau Testament
ça c'est
Isaïe 53
et c'est tellement explicite
donc regardez bien
combien avantageux était
pour Philippe
d'obéir
de manière
sacrificielle
et se soumettre
à l'influence
de son esprit
et donc le texte nous dit
que l'esprit dit à Philippe
de s'approcher
et s'asseoir
de courir après
et donc il est invité
à s'asseoir
pour commencer à partager
l'évangile
donc la première chose
pour nous
c'est d'être vraiment
soumis à la direction
du Seigneur
et la deuxième chose
c'est que comme Philippe
nous devons aussi
participer
de manière ordinaire
et intentionnelle
à la grande mission
du Christ
donc c'est très clair
pour nous
dans les passages
que Philippe
n'était pas
toujours en train
d'attendre un ange
pour partir en mission
donc si d'un côté
il y a la réalité
de ces influences
subjectives
du Saint-Esprit
la possibilité
qu'un ange même
apparaisse pour nous
de l'autre côté
il faut savoir reconnaître
qu'un ange
et que le Saint-Esprit
ne vont jamais
nous donner
une direction
qui sera contraire
à la direction biblique
c'était parfaitement
en harmonie
pour qu'il touche
donc les informations
qu'on va lire
à propos de l'éonuc et l'éthiopien
ne veulent pas
tout simplement pointer
sa position d'influence
dans la société
qui était
l'éonuc
responsable
pour tous les trésors
et ministre
des Candace
donc la reine d'Éthiope
l'Éthiope
qui était quand même
un empire assez puissant
et un homme
qui était comme si c'était
les Josephs
d'Éthiopie
sauf que
l'objectif
des Lucs ici
c'est de montrer
que l'église
à partir de ses tenuques
avance
dans la direction
des extrémités
de la terre
de l'accomplissement
du grand but missionnaire
des dieux
et Philippe
il était déjà engagé
en Judée
déjà engagé
en Saint-Marie
et il dit à Dieu
mais voici
j'y vais
donc plusieurs leçons
pour nous
sont importantes
déjà d'être
intentionnel
constant
dans une évangélisation
ordinaire
j'étais un jour
dans une conférence
missionnaire
et un monsieur
était en train
de me raconter
comment
s'est passé
son appel
pour aller
servir en tant que
missionnaire
aux États-Unis
et j'avoue
que la difficulté
dans mon cœur
c'est plus ou moins
la même
que pour lui
au départ
car c'est une nation
qui a tellement
déjà prospéré
avec l'évangile
il y a toujours
des besoins
dans tous les lieux
au monde
mais lui
il était réticent
et il a raconté
combien de fois
des personnes
ont dit avoir
reçu des prophéties
envers lui
et comment il a dû
voir une vision
d'une bannière
des États-Unis
devant lui
et il a raconté
plusieurs fois
il a résisté
et Dieu révélait
et tout
et après
qu'il a pris
presque 30 minutes
en train de raconter
l'histoire
20 minutes
il y en a une voix
d'un homme
beaucoup plus expérimenté
beaucoup plus âgé
qui dit
c'est drôle
comment Dieu
doit être si généreux
envers certains rébelles
car pour moi
il a suffit
d'élire
allez
faites des disciples
de toutes les nations
et je suis parti
et effectivement
cet homme-là
il avait implanté
énormément d'églises
beaucoup d'églises
en sortant de sa maison
en marchant
avec sa Bible
sous son bras
et donc
c'est pas pour supprimer
la possibilité
des visions spectaculaires
c'est juste pour dire
ça ne va jamais
aller dans une direction
contraire
à ce qui est déjà révélé
dans sa parole
la parole
est suffisante
et donc
nous devrions
nous engager
de manière très stratégique
très intentionnelle
envers les perdus
qui nous entourent
donc cette soumission
envers l'autorité
de Saint Jésus Christ
elle se donne
par ses deux fronts
une relation intime
avec le Saint-Esprit
qui nous a donné
sa parole
pour agir
à travers sa parole
on va traiter
je vais vous annoncer
tout simplement
les prochains points
et on va le traiter
la semaine prochaine
comme Philippe
nous devons
être capables
de proclamer
les seigneurs
Jésus Christ
à partir de l'Écriture
l'évangélisation
n'a pas lieu
jusqu'à ce qu'Écrit
soit clairement
annoncé
selon l'Écriture
et ses trente
Philippe accorut
et entendit
l'Éthiopien
qui lisait
les prophètes
Ésaïe
il lui dit
comprends-tu
ce que tu lis
il répondit
comment
les pourrais-je
si quelqu'un
ne me guide
et il inventa
Philippe à monter
et à s'asseoir
avec lui
les passages
d'Écriture
qu'il lisait
étaient celles-ci
il a été mené
comme un brébi
à la boucherie
et comme un agneau
moué
devant celui cléton
il n'a point
ouvert la bouche
dans son événation
son jugement
a été élevé
et sa postérité
qui la dépendra
car sa vie
a été retranchée
de la terre
et donc le nuque
dit à Philippe
j'étais pris
de qui
les prophètes
parlent-ils ainsi
est-ce que c'est
de lui-même
ou de quelques autres
alors Philippe
ouvrant la bouche
et commençant
par ses passages
lui annoncer
la bonne nouvelle
de Jésus
donc
juste pour introduire
ces points
étant
conduit
par l'aide
de Saint-Esprit
en soumission
à sa direction
en conformité
avec la parole
nous allons saisir
des occasions
avantageuses
pour l'évangélisation
mais de dire
tout simplement
Jésus tel
n'est pas
de l'évangélisation
de présenter
un avis personnel
à propos de Jésus-Christ
n'est pas
de l'évangélisation
ce n'est pas
mon idée
de Jésus
qui sauve
c'est la définition
biblique
de qui est
le vrai Jésus-Christ
qui peut sauver
quelle est sa vraie oeuvre
donc ici nous voyons
une évangélisation
qui commence avec
une bouche
grande
ouverte
d'échanger
philosophiquement
des théories
pour défendre
la double nature
du Christ
n'est pas
de l'évangélisation
ça peut fortifier
énormément
un jour
ils ont demandé
s'ils pouvaient
enregistrer
par translittération
à l'époque
la prédication
de Jonathan
et de l'autre
celui par qui
Dieu opérait
en réveil
en Amérique
sa réponse
elle était très intéressante
il a dit
vous pouvez le faire
sauf que
vous n'aurez pas
la capacité
d'enregistrer
les éclairs
et les tonnerres
la proclamation
de l'évangile
elle ne se donne pas
si tant par
tout simplement
une étude biblique
Dieu peut faire usage
l'usage d'un diapo
qui vous présente
toute la structure
du serment
elle est enracinée
dans la Bible
pour qu'on déclare
revêtu d'autorité
dans la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
la présence
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
les sauveurs
entre nous
son oeuvre
de rédemption
les vérités
qui concernent
notre salut
mais elle est
toujours aboutie
dans les moments
où l'interlocuteur
se trouve
non devant l'évangéliste
mais devant Dieu
qui lui parle
à travers l'évangéliste
Dieu a choisi
certains d'entre nous
pour être la bouche
des dieux
pour eux
mais à un moment donné
pour plus sophistiquer
qu'il soit l'intellect
d'un athée
et pour plus articuler
dans la connaissance
de la culture grecque
romaine
et internationale
car Philippe était
quand même quelqu'un
d'assez intellectuel
apparemment
comme Paul était aussi
énormément intellectuel
et qu'est-ce que Paul nous dit
j'ai choisi
de rien savoir
entre vous
à part Christ
et celui-ci
crucifié
des hommes
qui peuvent
rénoncer
de perdre du temps
avec toute sophistication
intellectuelle
sachant
que nous sommes
devant toujours
devant des créatures
des dieux
et qu'au fond de leur cœur
ils savent reconnaître
la voix des dieux
lorsqu'il
Dieu leur parle
et qu'ils sont
à la fin des comptes
rédévables
non
à ma capacité
en tant qu'évangéliste
sophistiqué
de dribbler
ses arguments
pour se défendre
des dieux
mais ils sont rédévables
devant Dieu
qui leur parle
malgré
parfois
la simplicité
de celui
qui est en train
de faire l'évangélisation
pourquoi
car Dieu
par les Saint-Esprits
est en train de manifester
Christ à cette personne
comme celui
qui est venu vivre
la vie parfaite
que personne n'arrive à vivre
et qui a été crucifié
ma place
pour payer
pour mes péchés
et donc cette
évangélisation
elle va conclure
avec
les versets 35
où Philippe
ouvrant bien la bouche
commençant
par ses passages
de l'écriture
sangulier
car c'est un seul livre
à la fin des comptes
un seul auteur
Dieu lui-même
lui annonça
la meilleure traduction
c'est pas la bonne nouvelle
Jésus-Christ
c'est
lui évangéliser
à Christ
car la proclamation
c'est la bonne nouvelle
c'est une proclamation
revêtue d'autorité
des rois
d'empire
car c'est ça
la notion d'évangile
avec les termes
de rendition
voici
votre seule opportunité
de vous réventir
c'est le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
lui-même
qui vous a donné
une occasion
de vous sauver
et si vous ne vous soumettez pas
vous serez un jour
complètement écrasé
donc c'est
de disparaître
quelque part
au milieu de l'évangélisation
et laisser la personne
devant Christ
lui-même
pour prendre une décision
lui annonça
Christ
quelle était la réponse
de l'éluge
il voit l'eau
quelque part
et dit
qu'est-ce qui m'empêche
d'être baptisé
je veux compromettre
ma carrière
ma position
car
son Seigneur
était comme un Dieu
dans sa culture
déclarer Christ
malgré sa position
très élevée
représentait beaucoup
de choses
en termes de renoncement
si tu crois
de tout ton coeur
et sa réponse
je crois
que le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
est le Fils des dieux
jusqu'à ce qu'une personne
ne répond pas ça
elle n'a pas été sauvée
mais elle ne peut pas répondre
ça
si une évangélisation authentique
n'a pas eu lieu
dans sa vie